[Music]
many black women struggle with
infertility but it can still be a very
taboo subject to talk about the
documentary eggs over easy wants to
change that black women infertility
hopes to shed light on the good and bad
of fertility Journeys and educate
younger women on their reproductive
options actor Calais Stewart became a
fertility Advocate after a very personal
realization
I was in a seven year relationship with
a very very fine man which is the
problem that's why I stayed longer than
I should have
but after we broke up I realized I was
37 years old I was single
I knew I always wanted to be a mother
and
one of the things that really hit me is
that I gave away my best baby making
years
to the wrong man
to the wrong relationship I didn't
realize that it wasn't just my effort or
my loyalty but that I was actually
giving away my biology and we don't
often think of it that way
we sure don't for black maternal Health
week we are joined by the documentaries
producer and director name is Shaquita
lockley an actor and fertility Advocate
you just saw kale Stewart good morning
to you good morning Kelly I have to
start with you number one guys the
documentary is knockout I got so many
Goosebumps and chills but that statement
that you made I gave away my biology
because I never thought about it that
way and later later on you said I knew I
could live my life without a
relationship I did not want to live my
life without a ma without being a mom
that's right I stayed in a relationship
past my best baby making years and I
knew I always wanted to be a mother but
I didn't know that I was giving away my
biology not just my time and my efforts
but actually my eggs because we are born
with as many eggs as we're ever going to
have and when you think about it that
way you will get out of an expired
relationship a lot sooner and so we
broke up on a Sunday and by Wednesday I
was at the fertility doctor to get
tested to see if I could freeze my eggs
because not only that but women are born
with the eggs we're going to have men
reproduce sperm every three months all
the time and you point out if men had
lows if this was an issue for men they
would have sperm banks set up on every
corner on every corner of the United
States of America I am you know I'm
convinced of that I'm convinced of that
too Shaquita this this is your
brainchild you produce this documentary
and one of the things you say is get off
of isolation Island ladies please
educate yourselves yeah so that's Robin
May's quote but
um most of the time we're in silos so
we're having these experiences but we
aren't talking about it in our group
chats we aren't talking about it with
our families this is not coming up at
Thanksgiving dinner we're not having
those conversations so if we talk about
it and normalize the conversation it
just makes it easier to get better
information out Shaquita what's the
title mean eggs over easy eggs over easy
so I was watching a reality show and one
of the um women screams at another one
is like that's why your eggs are rotten
and it hit deeply as if someone screamed
it me because in our culture we hear it
all the time you got scrambled eggs or
your eggs are rotten once you are
reaching a certain age
um so I just thought how do we make this
easier I mean we've been talking about
eggs forever what's an easier
conversation and so it was kind of a
no-brainer eggs over easy you mentioned
that it's a taboo subject we don't talk
about it enough why specifically in the
black communities of a taboo subject
well I have theories um first since
slavery when we had the Trope of fertile
Myrtle it's assumed that black women can
just have children and when you can't um
there's a shame attached to not being
able to do what Society tells you your
body should be able to do so that's
first and then second it's just Cost
prohibitive like your insurance is most
likely not paying for it because then
our country is not mandatory to cover
fertility issues or for your insurance
so how do you even pay for this is this
a conversation that we can have why
would we have it if it's not accessible
to us so I think those are probably two
of the biggest reasons just the shame
and the the money part of it of why
we're not having the conversation the
other thing that struck me guys in the
documentary is it's my uterus it's my
business don't ask insensitive questions
and all the questions that you all
raised don't ask when are you gonna do
it girl you know you can do it why is it
taking so long are things most people
have said and you're saying we need to
stop that we're supposed to talk about
it but how do we talk about without
offending people because most people
don't think they think they're asking it
very innocently yes and they're asking
with a good heart you know they mean
well but what we have to know is that we
haven't normalized these conversations
one of the things that I said in eggs
over easy is I threw myself an egg
shower because I've gone to so many baby
showers over the years and spent that
money and So after talking with Shaquita
and talking about it in the film I
recently partnered with Evite to create
Parenthood Journey which is now going to
be on that platform for egg showers IVF
showers rainbow showers and adoption
showers so hopefully that helps to
normalize the conversation hmm
Shaquita and you want us to do what now
there are Endless Options we just in the
news yesterday Hilary Swank gave birth
to twins at the age of 48. women look at
that and think okay I have a chance here
yeah so there are options I think we
have to ask early so as we're going into
doctors we need language to actually
talk to our doctor like what is an amh
you can um Google it I won't spend all
day talking about it but there are three
tests that can tell you where you are on
the fertility Spectrum if this is even
possible for you so we have to ask our
doctors and then doctors can be
proactive and instead of just saying do
you want birth control they can say do
you want to plan for your family
that should be included in every exam
for young girl so we start there and
then when we're planning for our careers
Felicia says that's one of our executive
producers plan for your body like you
plan for your career so you know where
you're going to work you know you're
going to go to grad school what are you
doing with your health thank you both
it's such a powerful documentary highly
recommend you can see eggs over easy on
own and discovery us we will be right
back
thank you